beauty gurus I hope that you have your
notebooks out and you're taking some
notes on how to set up a dynamic
background this would be the first time
I've talked out loud today No
snapchat isn't that sad hi guys my name
is grace Helbig if you did not know now
you know your life is different now it
is the end of the month of May is my
microphone plugged in unlucky for you
guys it is it's the end of May which
means it's time for monthly favorites
let's get into some of the stuff that I
have liked more than other stuff this
month out of applause for stuff I use
you guys to make me happy rather than
finding some sort of like internal
intangible form of happiness let's begin
first favourite yeah yes yeah yes yeah
okay I'll see ya
this is okay this is BB Mac contouring
one two three kit from dr. jart
dr. jart that sounds like dr. jarring
fart the classic dr. jart I got this off
of sephora.com on a whim it is a
contouring kit they're numbered one two
three come with this handy-dandy little
chart can you see that shows you the
best way that you should use these
things and I didn't think this was going
to be anything special but I bought it
anyway because but I tried this and I
really loved it I put it on today my
face is a little bit darker than the
rest of my body but if you're a dog you
don't see it so there's a highlighter a
neutral color and a bronzing color
there's something about the color of
this bronzer and the formula of it that
just kind of settles into my face
decently or maybe I just think that and
you guys are like you should take a look
at yourself when you edit this video and
think again and it comes in this handy
dandy noxious Liebig not great for
travel okay skew that yeah
yes IFA ami FAA Becca shimmering skin
perfecter press it's basically a shiny
powder look at that look at it it this
is in the color opal and it's just a
very nice shimmering thing to put on
your face in different areas I'm wearing
it here and here and here it gives you
like all the glowy benefits of being
pregnant without the baby part Oh Oh
cute next yeah yes aaaah aaaah aaaah
aaaah aaaah this is the collaboration
between Lilly Singh and Smashbox it's a
bow slip color I'm not wearing it today
little but I wore in my Billboard Music
Awards review video that you can go
check out there was a ton of compliments
on it and I really like this product the
job Lily saying it's a beautiful red
color that I think looks good on a lot
of people and it stays on your mouth
which is great for people like me who
are not good at keeping stuff on their
mouth it does not go anywhere it's like
that party guest that does not go
anywhere except this one's a much more
fun time good job Lilly catch-up
Smashbox big fan yeah yeah yes yeah hey
I'll see ya see ya this is glam glow
super mud clearing treatment all right
that's what this is this is a facial
mask for your face in a mask form it
looks like this well I'm almost
completely out of it I also got this on
Sephora calm in a glam glow kit because
I had heard someone on YouTube talking
about that brand and I thought this is
going to be kind of an okay product and
once I put on my face I really loved it
it comes with this little brush thing
that you can use to paint the mud mask
on your face and at first I was like
that's so stupid and then I actually
used it to paint on my face and I was
like I'm so stupid this is stupid fun
you keep your beautiful beautiful nails
clean I don't know what's in this mask
it's also patent pending which is
exciting because I interpret that as oh
there's some weirdness that probably
shouldn't be in this and officials
haven't officially taken it out yet cool
let's smack it on my face I really like
it made my skin feel really clean it
felt nice and cooling on my face we'll
see in time if it has negative side
effects Jude next now yeah say yeah yeah
say yeah I'll see ya this is a Beauty
Blender I'm sure
no this is if you don't it is meant to
blend in the beauty it's used to blend
in all the makeups on your face I got
this beauty blender at a Sephora in Las
Vegas over the weekend and it came in
this color the color of dirty Beauty
Blender now when I got my makeup on in
public I don't have to feel silently
judged by others thinking whoa that
girls aren't Beauty Blender is super
dirty instead it's just like whoa that
girl's sturdy Beauty Blender could be
super dirty but I don't know for sure
I'll take unsure judgement any day I
think this trend and going them further
than Beauty blenders I think they should
sell clothes with stains already on them
though computer cords already completely
tangled I think they should sell pints
of ice cream happy and this is only just
the beginning
yeah next yeah yes yeah yes yeah yes see
I have light blonde hair now and one way
to maintain light blonde air is purple
shampoo and purple conditioner I also
use this stuff it's red khun's blonde
Idol custom tone purple toner just about
color depositing daily treatment for
cool or platinum blondes I'm a cool bun
no I'm not there's this measurement
thing up here you can click over to see
how much you need to use I don't know
how this works at all I just when I wash
my hair I will add a little bit of this
to my shampoo and it gets purple
everywhere but I think my color holds on
stronger because of it and oh they sell
these at Ricky's I think I got this off
of Amazon maybe you should Google the
right way to use it if you want to use
it what an unhelpful way to be helpful
Exley's yes they are cafe yeah men's
t-shirts I recently been obsessed with
ordering men's t-shirts from Gap calm
and hmm calm and make in my opinion
cuter striped summer t-shirts where on
my short torso ladies at guys got set up
I cannot see you short torso joe men's
t-shirts can be cut a lot longer than
women's t-shirt so they fit me more
comfortably than women's t-shirts do and
so I've been ordering a lot of them see
that my
a style inspiration for the summer is
Dennis the Menace apparently also for
the short torso ladies and men out there
gotham sells t-shirts in size tall as
well as petite and the tall t-shirts are
very long and they give the wonderful
illusion that your torso is longer than
it actually is we can overcome anything
next I can't say I am say it moleskin
notebooks these are notebooks made by
the brand moleskin I do not think
they're actually made out of moleskin if
they are made out of moleskin it's all
take a deep breath and repress right
moleskin notebooks I love I love getting
the ones that don't have any lines on
them so that I can sort of write out all
my nonsense ideas all over I have so
many notebooks ones that aren't used
ones that aren't unwrapped I think I
just like surrounding myself with
notebooks because the idea of notebooks
makes me feel like I have so many ideas
to come up with in order to fill these
pages next yeah yep yeah yeah say yeah
yeah say yeah this is a book called the
new astrology that Val who does my
makeup very often for things and events
actually bought for me because she's a
huge fan of this book and I love it it's
by Suzanne white a unique synthesis of
the world's two great astrological
systems the Chinese and Western so this
book basically combines
zodiac and astrology I believe basically
you find out your astrological sign I'm
a Libra and then your Chinese zodiac
animal which is based on the year that
you are born I'm an ox I'm a Libra ox
and then you can go in here you can read
more about your sign Libra and then you
can read more about your specific combo
Libra ox and a lot of it is really
spot-on and if you're interested in this
stuff at all this is a great book for it
because not only can you read your
Chinese Western combo you can read
everyone around use combo and it helps
give you sneaky sneaky insight into the
psychology of the people around you
especially if you are dating and you
meet someone new and you don't know much
about them you can find out some more
about them so if you like astrology this
is a really great book and also having a
giant book around gives people the
illusion that you're
like really interested in the world look
at this interesting person I am next and
laugh yeah yes say yes say yes say it's
dish and I'm gonna be mentioning this
every favorite video so heads-up dish is
the food photo app that Hannah and
mamrie Ingrid and myself have gotten
behind and it's awesome dys H if you
haven't downloaded already we also
recently launched dish feeds which is
the give back program that is part of
dish what happens with dish is when you
post photos of food and review dishes
and restaurants you get points and as
you get points on your profile you move
up different levels of dish and when you
move up different levels dish donates
meals to the hungry it's an incredible
program we started this month and let's
see what are we up to already two
thousand four hundred and seventy four
meals donated this month which is
incredible awesome job to everyone that
is actively participating a dish much
much love and respect for you and for
those that haven't done it yet you are
dead to me until you do and then
reincarnation is a thing turns out haha
so download the chef if you haven't
already all the links for my profile and
the app itself are in the description of
this video and that did burn my may
favorites I hope you guys enjoyed this
video let me know what you've been
loving this month and I would love if
you subscribe to this channel that would
just make my day and more I don't know
this upstairs on your lips longer than
the Steven Tyler stays my everything
that got away from me